luxury in China is not frivolous it's
not superficial in China only 1% would
say that luxury products are superficial
pursuits luxury is a tool of success on
the battlefield of life
I'm deaf engineer and I created so
Dalian which is a boarding event in the
north of China in every of the event we
are developing we are trying to bring
lifestyle and to bring experience we
have to show the customer what you can
do on board how you can enjoy on all the
fine things like strawberry champagne
caviar cigars we actually teach in them
educating because we're Chinese people
they used to work hard right we used to
work hard and they don't know how to
enjoy their free time we have to
remember 30 years ago China was an
incipient basket case I mean it was
total isolation having a call as a
luxury I mean everybody was on bicycle
so going from complete isolation to huge
transformation China's on the biggest
market for all the Western luxury brands
and the new generation now who happens
to actually leave the life of their
parents want to discover something new
you know full moon hanami talking about
what is Sam helped a young teenage who
she wanted to tourism moment as firm
able to run do the sugar Jordan sound
vide shadowy mutant Widow just us and
the she chose announced nobility so when
we started to develop the boating
industry they were quite a challenge
because some didn't want to face the Sun
or couldn't swim and that's why the key
was to bring them on the water and to
offer them the opportunity to discover
the great excitement of co- Ellen
I tell all my customers
what is the difference we have 500
million or 600 million u.s. there's a
big difference you of 1 million 10
million 100 million there's a great
difference but there is no difference
anymore you have 500 million or 600
millions just to figure enjoy your life
you can feel how exploding in your mouth
and then beautiful liquid is covering
your mouth all over it we organized the
first beach polo tournament in China
equestrian activities are considered as
noble sport so that's why it's
attracting a lot of upper-class people
the idea is to develop international
communities and club you have the same
values you feel the same things actually
wherever you are from you are from your
same you know you know category
Oh jumbo ticket even my fidelity omean
me Enzo's well my aha
so Tatiana me hodo she hung any job my
own tote Ranjini face is the currency of
forward advancement phases
acknowledgement that other people give
you but it's translated into getting
them to do things for you and it's
generated according to a very opaque
network of associations all those
high-end activities in a way will help
them to do networking too because never
forget that Chinese never disconnect in
doing business that like in every
country you want to belong to the upper
class that's what you aim to when you're
working you are trying to do your best
to be on the top you so lifestyles so in
which legal which level you are playing
I strongly believe this yachting will be
booming it's just a question of time
the China market is the future of the
legume market and there are many people
that say that it's bound to tail off but
my opinion it's not going to tail off
money will not become something that is
crude because it is a meritocratic
marker of success and one thing about
the Chinese is they revel in the
concrete and the quantifiable to me it's
still a little bit of a mystery what
exactly the Chinese dream is I've lost
my friends I've asked my driver and I
asked my assistants is what you think
this means I think it's a promise it's a
hope for everybody to improve their
lives in a time right now where you know
that is a big rich-poor divide if it's
something that brings the other 99% know
that do not hold the country's wealth
give them something to work towards it's
hard if you're not being a communist
country anymore and you're being
capitalist then you are going to have
those differences it's natural